Can you mention briefly again categorize
the uh common errors made in the third
category?
The common errors committed by Muslims
in the third category that is errors
regarding negligence in performing the
farad the obligate duties in Islam is
that Muslims
many of them they stay awake the full
night.
They have a early sur and
these people
they do not offer the fajar salah.
Missing fajar salah is a sin.
Many of them because they stay awake the
full night. They sleep the full day and
they even miss their zuhar and the assar
salah which is a grave sin. You're
trying to acquire blessings and you are
neglecting the obligated duties which is
totally prohibited.
Many of the Muslims
they do not give zakat. Those are
supposed to give zakat. And zakat is one
of the pillars of Islam in which every
Muslim who has a saving of the nisab
level that is those who have a saving of
85 g of gold they should give 2.5%
of their savings every lunar year in
charity. It's called as zakat.
And the fourth error in the third
category is that most of the Muslims
give zakat but they do not calculate the
zakat properly.
As far as common errors committed by
Muslim month of Ramadan that is
indulging in prohibited acts the most
common is though these acts are
prohibited for a Muslim irrespective
whether it's a month of Ramadan or non
Ramadan but specifically we should be
more careful. We should be careful
trying to avoid these acts throughout
the life. But in Ramadan, we should be
more careful. And the most common number
one where Muslims involve themselves is
backbiting and slandering.
Backbiting is a grave sin. And Allah
says in the Quran in surah Jarat chapter
49 verse number 12 that those who
backbite they are people who eat the
dead meat of their own brother.
So backbiting and slandering is one of
the gravest sins. The second common
error in this category is
Muslims. Many of them they use false
speech. They tell lies during the month
of Ramadan.
The third is they use abusive language
which is contrary to the spirit of Islam
and of
the fourth is they use vulgar language
and the fifth is they involve themselves
in gossiping.
The sixth is
some of them involve in false action.
The seventh is many of the Muslims
to kill time they listen to music and
unislamic songs
which is totally prohibited in Islam.
The eighth common error is many of the
Muslims to kill time they watch
unislamic television programs and
unislamic movies.
The ninth common error committed by
Muslim is that many of the Muslims they
read unislamic magazines, unislamic
books, and Islamic pictures which are
all private in Islam. The 10th common
error done by Muslims in this month is
many of them they go to unislamic sites
on the internet which is again
prohibited.
The 11th common error is that they
spend excessively
and they commit extravagance.
And the 12th is there is a lot of
wastage of food. So this was in brief
regarding
the list of mistakes done by Muslims
commonly in the third category that is
indulging in acts which are prohibited
and neglecting acts which are first in
Islam.
>> So Dr. Zakia what are the other common
errors committed by Muslims during the
month of Ramadan?
The other common errors committed by
Muslims in the month of Ramadan. That is
the fourth category is number one is
that many of the Muslims they stay awake
the full night and then they sleep in
the day and they do the normal
activities at night time and sleep in
the daytime. They're converting day into
night and night into day and the whole
purpose of fasting is defeated. The
second error in this category is that
many of the Muslims they remain lazy and
are inactive during the daytime which is
contrary to the spirit of fasting. The
third common error is that many of the
Muslims they try and kill their time
during the day by playing
by amusement by games which defeats the
purpose. Again
the fourth common error is Muslims they
give lavish iftar parties and they spend
a lot of money mainly trying to show
off. The fifth common error. Many of the
Muslims they ask the woman folk in their
family to prepare a variety of dishes
for ifar and for sour. Thus making the
woman in the family spend the majority
of the time in the kitchen. In fact, the
family should spend most of the time in
remembering Allah subhana wa ta'ala. And
if the women folk do more duas,
inshallah, even the men will benefit.
Even their sins will be forgiven
inshallah.
The sixth common error is that many of
the Muslims, they renovate
the house and their shop in the month of
Ramadan, spend more time in that than
remembering Allah subhana wa t'ala. The
seventh common error is that many of the
Muslims
they spend their nights instead of
remembering Allah subhana wa ta'ala in
activities which are unproductive for
example
they spend their time
in excessive socializing afterawi
that is eight error ninth is many of the
Muslims they spend many nights and most
parts of their nights in shopping.
The 10th common error is many of the
Muslims they spend most of their time in
the night in eating.
The 11th is many of the Muslims they
spend their time in robing
and in loitering during the night. And
the 12th common error is the last 10
days of Ramadan are mainly the days in
which the Muslims should do more ibada.
But most of the Muslims they spend time
in shopping in celebrating
and preparing themselves for Eid
and most of them spend time in
activities which are unproductive rather
than spending the time in ibada. These
are some of the other common errors
which Muslims commit and I hope
inshallah that they will abstain from
these errors in future.